hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another installment of what
you never knew this is where we look
back in movies you've seen a million
times but still managed to miss one or
two little details with that said let's
take a look at one of my favorite
comedies ever hot fun
[Music]
this is arguably the world's greatest
satire of American action movies it's
fast it's clever every bit of dialogue
comes back into play one way or another
it's one of the most ingenious comedies
of all time so ingenious that chances
are you'd missed one or two subtle
touches that work this way right past
you and we're here to look at them today
now it goes without saying you have to
have seen the movie to get all these so
a lot of plot details are going to be
revealed or deployed another way but
they're not behind the scenes facts are
nitpicking plot holes they're just the
kick-ass little moments you never
realize we're making the movie more
kick-ass so let's not waste any time
let's take a look at hot foot
[Music]
cameo time hello Steven Coogan
hello Kate Blanchet hello Peter Jackson
hello Davy Jones hello Nicholas angel
yep
Nicholas angel the main character is
actually named after the music
supervisor a Shaun of the Dead the
world's end and of course Hot Fuzz I
guess he must have been a really nice
guy
the fact is you've been making sue look
bad I'm sorry sir
well sergeant angel gets attention for
operation crackdown he's also gotten
awards for two other operations and yes
if you read them in order they are
operations crack down shake down and
take down speaking of which all the
people who will eventually end up as
villains in this movie also had very
cryptic last names including Hatcher
Skinner Reaper and shooter while on the
subject of names
Nora Street where a lot of the action
takes place is also named after cheese
star Chuck Norris who's even referenced
in the movie and did you ever notice
this joke supposed to go through the
whole phonebook yeah according to Alan
Aronson shall we name our nerds sorry a
lot of people miss that the first time
[Music]
this arcade game appears in every single
film in the Cornetto trilogy that being
sure the Dead Hot Fuzz and World's End
as well as this fence joke
you're probably wondering why is it
called the Cornetto trilogy that's
because every film has a Cornetto ice
cream dish in it and in a bizarre
inspiration from Christoph Kowalski's
three-color film trilogy yes they
actually do kind of make a reference to
that their colors symbolize an element
of the film ensure the dead it's red for
zombies in Hot Fuzz it's blue for police
and in World's End
it's green for aliens yeah okay nothing
deep is symbolism but it's still there
you're saying this wasn't an accident
Hot Fuzz is actually praised by police
from one realistic portrayal of crown
work can you guess what it is
no definitely not it's actually the
paperwork most officers point out that
the paperwork is never addressed in cop
films yet this one shows it being done
after every single event many were happy
that arguably the most annoying and
tedious part of the job was finally
getting some recognition good catch
there's no way you could perpetrate that
Matakana you may have not incur a
considerable math paperwork while we're
on the subject three-fourths of the film
is pointing out why LA the actions in
well action movies couldn't happen in
real life because of this the film tries
to account for the lack of action by
making mundane things look like intense
action-packed moments even though little
is going on
additionally when the film's climax does
decide to indulge in every action film
cliche known to man
a lot of the mundane line said before
subtly come back as classic badass
one-liners did you ever notice that when
Timothy Dalton drive by a murder scene
there's always a fitting song playing
for example when he tries by the dead
actors from Romeo and Juliet the song
Romeo and Juliet is play only drives by
the flaming corpse of another victim a
song emphasizing fire is played
[Applause]
[Music]
this isn't surprising seeing how the
sound design team often reinforces in
foreshadows what's going to happen in
the film like cutting the hedge clippers
for shadows this woman's death I was
just about to pop off we're indicating a
staff stupidity with a wrong answer
buzzer my work listen closely and you'll
hear them all throughout the film
I'm the chief inspector any windows for
shadowing the character's deaths are
also all over the place some obvious
hopefully that's the last we'll see of
him I'll make sure everyone gets there
just as a kind of so well I said kinda
pack it in Frank you silly bastard well
this certainly is a mystery trying to be
solved most people miss there actually
are two being set up the cool unquote
real one centers around the tackiness
and non rustic nature of people who need
to be axed off for the neighborhood's
peaceful appearance but there is another
totally plausible murder plot about a
bypass land ownership expanding
corporations you see the land merchant
was buying a little value in of itself
who'll be a prime location for say a
retail park it all falls ingeniously
into place except for the fact that it
just wasn't the motive in reality the
motives were much more childish and
juvenile making the joke all the more
hilarious
blowers was simply the result of his
being and I'm Paul and you murdered him
for that but he might have bill
Shakespeare what this film is like the
psycho or vertigo of comedies writing
such a complicated and clever setup only
to have it lead to something completely
different
pretty damn clever or about the greater
good
the swear jar has all the words you
can't say blocked out except for
arguably the most offensive word in the
English language that one is shown in
its entirety priorities I guess well
come on a sentimental note we see Danny
and his father at the carnival get
dressed up in the exact same cowboy
outfits they wore when Danny's mother
was still alive showing he still has
that quite sensitive side to it though
not sensitive enough not to pull out a
club on a swan I love that an
interesting notion Sanford has a city
model where part of the climax takes
place it's possible that one of the ways
Sanford wants to be a model city is to
literally have a model city even the
science sort of reinforces that it wants
you to associate that term with the town
also interesting to note that while
Dalton attacks the journalist with the
steeple it's fitting revenge that a
steeple is what ends up attacking him
and of course just as Bruce ibly you
might have noticed very quickly that
Fisher is not the best officer what are
we ready Hey
[Music]
if you didn't get before perhaps this
subtle image might help and the number
one thing you never knew about Hot Fuzz
is nobody dies in the climax yeah think
about it it's violent its gory it has
all the action cliches expected out such
a scene but bizarrely enough
every single person lives and goes to
jail my thought is that maybe angel is
so diehard of being a good police
officer and going by the book that he
never officially kills anyone that is
what a cop is supposed to do right give
them out the situation as peaceful as
possible and while Danny always talks
about those great action scenes where
they blow up a whole bunch of guys in
this one not one ever gets killed off so
they end up playing in both their ways
the only one who I assume doesn't get
out alive is the guy who knocks into the
bomb at the end but even then so many
people unrealistically make it out that
it's strangely possible he might have to
I don't know if someone can survive this
why couldn't someone survive this well
even if he does get axed off it still
was an angel who killed him he does
knocked him on his feet leaving him
totally murderous and still the best cop
that Sanford's ever had which ties in
all the more to the consistency and
kick-ass nature this awesome comedy has
to offer
[Music]
are there any more that we missed are
there eight little details we're talking
about well leave them in the comment
section below and keep talking about
movie that's definitely worth talking
about I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to
[Music]